hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy and we're entering into
yet another back to school but this is a
back to school that's very unusual
compared to all others
we hope that we're finally going to get
to some level of normalcy as we
see the light at the end of the tunnel
with the pandemic at least in some
places i know a lot of parts of the
world are still
going through some of the worst impacts
of of the pandemic
but as we hopefully get to that point
and go back to school
i just wanted to say how excited we are
to partner with y'all
the pandemic has been tough it's been
tough on many dimensions of our life but
especially education
uh as i always say and and people are
surprised to hear it from me
if i had to pick between an amazing
in-person experience with an amazing
educator
versus the best technology in the world
i would pick the amazing in-person
experience now i don't think there has
to be a trade-off
i think the best is the best of both
worlds but you could imagine
people haven't had the benefit of being
in the room together being able to have
all of the intangibles that goes
uh with being an in-person school so
there's a lot of work to do
obviously all of us here at khan academy
have been doing our best
to play a part in keeping everyone
learning supporting everyone
as the pandemic went on but the real
work is actually going to be now as we
go into back to school
a lot of folks have been talking about
unfinished learning or learning loss
and every summer there's some learning
loss kids forget things and they're not
learning things
but we can imagine with a year year and
a half of
of pandemic schooling some of the kids
who
we are most concerned about actually
fell off the radar and many many other
kids
uh weren't able to learn as much and
even the kids and the learners i should
say of all ages who were able to learn
there's other things that fell by the
wayside the socialization the connection
the hue the patterns of school
so for all of you parents
students teachers donors to khan academy
first of all thank you for being on this
journey with us
but i'm confident as well that as we go
into this period it's not going to be
easy but if we work together
figure out ways to finish that
unfinished learning there might be a
post-pandemic world where
we can accelerate learning together
faster than ever
so i look forward to going on that
journey and welcome back to school
you